all right be good you can't be good okay
love you guys okay
who can give me the derivative of X
let's go it off did you guys see that
at 1:07 a.m. the Odyssey satellite
received images of an object moving past
Mars it's right over us
I didn't know it then but that was the
last normal day of my life
we agreed to believe is I'm going to
threat to this location all right stay
with your sister the waves have begun
started coordinated attacks on
metropolitan areas
the first wave knocked out all the power
then the second made
an earthquake strong enough to shake the
entire planet
with the third way disease spread across
the world by the fourth wave they were
among us the others have the ability to
inhabit human hosts they could be
anywhere we can't trust anyone anymore
the others took my brother and I'm gonna
go get him
you will learn to think move and fight
like soldiers I want to be ready you
won't get very far on your own grab the
gun and snap my hand away good I was
supposed to fight them throwing an old
day off
what are you they took everything from
me
well school yeah this is our world
this is our home
our only choice is to take it back drop
it I know you're human
hell because if you were wanted then you
would have shot me already